today on the matt wall show the cdc has
extended the eviction moratorium once
again forbidding property owners from
evicting tenants who don't pay their
rent
biden admits that um this isn't
constitutional and he has no authority
to do what he's doing and yet he does it
anyway
this is what it's like to live in a
lawless country we'll talk about that
also we have our five headlines
the new york attorney general releases
her report detailing governor cuomo's
serial sexual harassment but
i'm still mostly concerned about the
fact that cuomo killed
thousands of elderly people that to me
seems like the bigger deal plus
the nih director says that parents
should wear masks in their homes
to protect their children and later
backtracks in our daily cancellation
we'll talk about the rapper who's in the
middle of a pr
crisis because of his comments that he
made about gay people
yet this rapper says many more
objectionable things in his songs and
few people seem to have a problem with
that
we'll discuss that confusing
contradiction and much more today on the
matt wall show
well you may not realize this but it's
not fun to feel sick
i don't know if you've ever experienced
that in your life i have i wouldn't
recommend it necessarily
and if you don't like feeling sick then
relief band is
for you relief band is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness which is my which is the
scourge
that i deal with um anxiety migraine
hangover morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more
the product is 100 drug free non-drowsy
and provides all natural relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed
the great thing is this technology was
originally developed in hospitals you
know decades ago
and for a while was only available to
patients in hospitals but now through
relief band it's it's
available to the masses and it what it
does is it stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of
your brain that controls nausea and then
it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you
that you are sick ensure nausea is never
the reason to miss out on life's
important moments right now relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for matt
walsh listeners if you go to
reliefband.com these promo code wall
should receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee
so head to reliefband.com
and use our promo code walsh for 20 off
if the last 18 months have taught us
anything it's that we live in a
fundamentally lawless country
the law is dead in america we have laws
certainly lots of them more laws than
any nation has ever had i'm sure
new bills are all like war and peace
both because they're over a thousand
pages and because nobody's
actually read them our problem is not
then a scarcity of laws
this is not a problem of quantity the
problem is that there is no foundational
underlying law which everyone including
our leaders
recognize and abide by all of these new
laws and policies spring forth out of
the imagination of politicians
and unelected bureaucrats they're not
meant to serve any greater purpose
except the political and ideological
needs of the ruling class
and this state of affairs would be quite
bad but not
as bad as it actually is if these
arbitrary edicts
were enforced equally but they're not
winners and losers are
chosen by that same ruling class if they
decide they can wave their
scepters and excuse certain groups of
people from the duty to obey even the
most
basic and universal laws as we all
witnessed when bloodthirsty mobs
rioted and looted in our cities for
months and few in that crowd
have faced any legal penalties for it
of course i say there is no foundational
underlying law which everyone must abide
by but
i mean that in a practical sense that
law does
exist in theory and it's called the
constitution but
the constitution is just a document it's
not a deity
it doesn't possess the supernatural
ability to enforce
itself those in power must
choose to heed it if they don't
then it may as well not exist see we can
scream that's unconstitutional all we
want but
the people in power simply shrug their
shoulders and respond yeah so what
what are you going to do about it and
that's where we are now in where we were
yesterday when the cdc extended its
eviction moratorium
for another two months now this
moratorium was
initially put in place last september as
the cdc
stood upon its mighty perch on mount
olympus and declared that property
owners are not allowed to evict tenants
from their property even if those
tenants refuse to pay
the cdc of course has absolutely no
actual
authority whatsoever to set housing
policy
in fact if you look at the cdc's website
and you read its mission statement
here's what it says
cdc works 247 to protect america from
health safety and security threats both
foreign and in the u.s
whether diseases start at home or abroad
or chronic or acute curable or
preventable
human error or deliberate attack cdc
fights disease and supports communities
and citizens to do the same
now they're clearly doing a very bad job
at all of that but
you'll notice that even in their own
description of themselves and what they
do
they don't say anything about housing
policy
leave that as it may they made the
policy anyway
and it expired over the weekend the
white house admitted after it expired
that the executive branch does not have
the authority to extend it biden
said this and then called on the
legislator to act said they're gonna
they're gonna have to be the ones to do
it we can't do it
and by the way it's arguable dubious in
fact i would say right now
even congress doesn't really have the
constitutional authority to
declare that all landlords across the
entire country cannot evict any tenants
tenants um
but congress didn't act and so biden
said
okay never mind we'll go ahead and do
the thing that i just admitted
we don't have the authority to do and
the moratorium was extended on a limited
basis we're told
oh it's limited this time except that
it still applies to 90 percent of the
population that's what counts as
limited in the federal government's eyes
90 percent
uh the the extended moratorium also
comes with criminal penalties for any
property owner who
dares to kick out a squatter from their
property a reporter from business
insider reports quote
the new 60-day cdc eviction moratorium
carries steep criminal penalties for
individual landlords who break the law
potential 100 000 fine and one year in
jail if eviction doesn't result in death
up to 250 000 fine and uh and one year
in jail if evicted person dies
and what do we even mean by that like
it's eviction that results in
death i mean if you evict someone by
throwing them out
the tenth story window then i can see
how that's an eviction that results in
death
but if you evict someone because they're
not paying and then later on they die
how is that your fault and how do we
even is it is it if i evict you
and then you die tomorrow that's my
fault what if you die six months from
now
and and and let's back up even further
breaks
the law what law
no law has been passed is the cdc now a
legislative entity
apparently we're supposed to believe
that it is they're passing laws now
now biden for his part admitted in a
press conference last night
that the moratorium is probably not
constitutional and will probably get
struck down in court
but the good news he says is that it
will take a while before that happens
and uh there's a lot of power grabbing
we can do in the meantime let's listen
the bulk of the constitutional
scholarship
says that it's not likely to pass
constitutional muster
number one but there are several key
scholars
who think that it may and it's worth the
effort but
the present you could not the courts
already ruled on the present
eviction moratorium so i think what
you're going to see and i
look i want to make it clear i told you
i would not tell the justice department
or the
medical experts or scientists what they
should say or do
so i don't want to get ahead the cdc has
to make this i ask the cdc to go back
and consider other options that may be
available to them
you're going to hear from them what
those other options are
i have been informed they're about to
make a judgment
as the potential other options whether
that option
will pass constitutional
measure with this administration i can't
tell you
i don't know there are a few scholars
who say it will
and others who say it's not likely to
but
at a minimum by the time it gets
litigated
it will probably give some additional
time
while we're getting that 45 billion
dollars out to people
who are in fact behind in the rent and
don't have the money
okay let me just interpret what uh
translate what mr magoo is saying here
uh the president united states is
admitting openly
that he is engaging in an
unconstitutional power grab that almost
certainly will not pass muster in the
courts
only he says well by the time the courts
can do anything about it
it'll be too late now he's far from the
first president
to engage in an unconstitutional power
grab i mean they
they all have going back decades and
decades decades
but um what is arguably unusual
is that he should be so forthright about
it
once again the message is yeah this is
unconstitutional
what are you peons going to do about it
well we know who isn't going to do
anything about it republicans
as the president united states engages
in this unprecedented unconstitutional
power grab
admitting again that it is
unconstitutional republicans have very
little to say about it
the cdc has assumed the power to write
legislation
and has removed property rights from
millions of americans in the process
property rights one of the most
fundamental rights you can have if you
don't have property rights
then you don't have rights you do not
live in a free country
there is no such thing as a free country
where you don't have property rights
and this is happening and our trusty
conservatives quote unquote in the
republican party can hardly be bothered
to vocally object to it
saying almost nothing about it now
perhaps if this was happening in
cuba or the middle east republicans will
be a little bit more upset
but the rights of actual americans seem
to not really be a priority
of either party speaking of those actual
americans
um you know the law
the constitution our basic property
rights are all being set on fire for the
sake of protecting
millions of renters who allegedly can't
pay their rent
except that those renters live in a
country with
millions of open jobs and have
collectively received
billions of dollars in assistance
already
just in the past year sorry not billions
trillions trillions of dollars in
assistance have been passed
and is available and the checks have
been cut and have been sent
to these people and we're supposed to
believe that millions of them still
can't pay their rent sorry no
i don't buy it not for a second
if they haven't paid their rent in a
year it's because they've chosen
not to it's because they've chosen not
to
they've decided to steal and yes
if you've been living in a rented
property for a year
or almost a year now and haven't paid a
dime towards it
you're stealing and they're doing it
because they know that the federal
government will assist them in the
appropriation of someone else's property
what is happening here is that private
property is being
taken appropriated and given to
other parties as essentially a form of
welfare
as for the landlords though they are
painted as some shadowy group of wealthy
evil land barons the fact is that a
great number
number of them are middle class
individual investors
they're experiencing real suffering and
hardship which has been caused not by a
virus
or any act of god but by a combination
of the government
who believe that they are god and greedy
mooching tenants
many people are on the brink or already
over it
so just as an example let me share with
you a couple of stories um a number of
property owners with
uh rental properties have have messaged
me as i've been talking about this over
the last few days
to tell me what they've been going
through and uh the media isn't gonna
tell you these stories so
let me just read a couple okay and these
are representative these are not
extreme outlying things this is this is
what what
thousands of thousands of people are
going through right now so let me read a
couple here's one
my wife and i own two houses our home we
live in in a previous home that we
decided to rent out
we got a tenant in at the end of last
year and received the first two months
rent after that he kept giving me
excuses for not paying
then suddenly he changed his phone
number and wouldn't contact me i went to
the house multiple times over the next
month and it appeared abandoned i went
through the proper steps even getting
state legislatures looking at loopholes
in the moratorium
but because the tenant wouldn't make
contact with me to confirm he was
abandoning the property i wasn't allowed
to evict him
the state of minnesota has a rental
assistance program to help with this but
because the tenant wasn't communicating
i wasn't eligible for support you see
apparently they would pay him if i
wouldn't cooperate on the application
but they won't pay me
if he doesn't cooperate makes sense
right shortly after this
the utilities were allowed to be shut
off but now that it was summer i needed
the ac to run so that it wouldn't
destroy
the interior of the house so now we're
paying the mortgage and the utilities on
a house we don't live in
it's been seven months now that the
moratorium has ended i was legally
required to email the tenant
who again hasn't lived in my house in
months to let him know he wasn't
he that he was being evicted but he
replied that he would like to apply for
assistance from the state
and now i am legally required to go
through that process we are now waiting
on the state to pay me back rent
but there's no guarantee we will receive
that money it's tough to pay two
mortgages
two utilities and take care of two
houses by the way the rent slash
mortgage
are over a thousand dollars a month
and that's a there's a lot in there
that's important but one important point
and i got i got i've heard this from
many
people in this position that you know if
you're hearing oh well the landlords can
get rental assistance or there's
assistance for them
there are a lot of loopholes you have to
go through and a lot of contingencies
and one thing i'm hearing over and over
again is that if if you're a landlord
and you want to get paid back your
tenants have to cooperate with that
and help you out and if they don't then
you're out of luck
um here's another it says i lost my job
when covet hit my wife wasn't working as
we just had our third child i was not
entitled to welfare due to assets a
rental property with a mortgage of 500
000
when the tenant sent a letter stating
that they had received advice that they
did not have to pay rent
and we could not kick them out in the
meantime the tenants were now making
more money than they were
when they started renting i dread the
damage i'm up for when we finally get
them out in october this year
as they have not let the agent inspect
since covet hit
i have felt close to the brink and one
more it says i'm working all
all the overtime i can so i can still
pay the mortgage on my rental property
so they can live there for free i don't
think that they lost their jobs
either they're just gaming the system i
have a couple of friends
in the same situation there are many
many more stories where the these can
come from many thousands more this is
real suffering brought on by real
tyranny
from an oppressive government which
recognizes no law
outside of itself no limit
except its own imagination
which brings us back to where we started
there is no law in this country anymore
but there is a government and it's
simply doing whatever it wants
now let's get to our five headlines
well given the subject uh to begin the
show today about our tyrannical
overlords and their lawlessness there
couldn't be a better time to tell you
about ben shapiro's latest book if you
haven't heard us talk about it yet
the authoritarian moment which does a
deep dive into the history of
authoritarianism and how it's creeping
into our own government and most
importantly what you can do to stop it
so it's time to learn how to say no to
this tyrannical government
the authoritarian moment is now
available at amazon barnes noble or any
other major bookseller so get your copy
now
again that's the authoritarian moment on
sale today
so my wife and kids quick update from
from the homestead my wife and kids are
currently
in the midst of a full-on pressure
campaign to convince
me to get a dog
and the thing is we talked about the dog
thing
you know i'm obviously not a dog person
to put it mildly i think that is a
well-established
fact but i could maybe be convinced to
consider a dog
that would be good with the kids and
like a good companion for the kids
um because the kids of course like all
kids they love dogs
but most importantly a guard dog right
so because i don't i don't really i'm
not a big dog guy but but lots of
i don't really like dogs but lots of
people really don't like me
really really don't like me so we have
security concerns in my family
and i've already put in place plenty of
security measures of course but having a
big scary
dog that's you know protective and all
of that from everything i've heard that
that's kind of like the second best
security thing you can have
aside from from uh owning a gun might
even be in some cases better
than the gun though really you know
there's no reason we have to choose
between the two but in terms of just
like uh
dissuading someone from even making
attempt in the first place so i'm
thinking about that i'm considering it
and then my my wife ends up going to a
shelter with the kids
yesterday and starts frantically texting
me pictures
of all of these different dogs and some
of them are small and old and lethargic
she was trying at one point to convince
me to to adopt like this 12 year old
miniature corgi looking thing what the
hell is that thing gonna
what is it going to guard a lego house
and uh you know and she says oh
look at all these dogs they're cute
these cute dogs
well okay yeah they're cute but but if
i'm
gonna have a dog in the house
uh it needs to do a lot more than be
cute okay it has to serve
some purpose other than being cute we
already have cute in the house
we the kids are cute we've got the cute
quotient
covered like i'm not getting up at five
o'clock in the morning or whatever to
take this thing for a walk
and consoling myself by saying well at
least it's cute
i could maybe console myself by the
thought that uh
that the dog is helping my wife and kids
be safe and feel safe
i'm you know i'm willing to invest in
that i'm just not willing to invest in
cute
you got to do better than cute i mean
cute isn't even good enough for my kids
my daughter can't get out of doing
chores by saying well but daddy i'm cute
okay well yeah they get upstairs and
clean your room be cute cleaning your
room that's the cutest thing you can do
right now
so that's uh
it's my mistake for opening the door in
the first place i never should have done
that i never should have entertained the
possibility of a dog
and uh and this is where we are now okay
um number one the new york attorney
general announced yesterday that after
an investigation
it has been determined that governor
cuomo is a serial sexual harasser which
i think we already kind of knew but they
did a full investigation
and did a press conference released the
whole report here is the attorney
general
describing some of their findings let's
watch
the independent investigation has
concluded
that governor andrew cuomo sexually
harassed multiple women
and in doing so violated federal and
state law
specifically the investigation found
that
governor andrew cuomo sexually harassed
current
and former new york state employees by
engaging in unwelcome and non-consensual
touching
and making numerous offensive comments
of a suggestive
and sexual nature that created a hostile
work
environment for women
the investigators independently
corroborated and substantiated these
facts
through interviews and evidence
including contemporaneous notes and
communications
this evidence will be made available to
the public
along with the report okay he created a
a hostile work environment
for uh for women he was sounds like he's
just sort of a pig and a jerk to women
and there's the whole report was
released you could read the entire
report if for some reason you want to
now governor cuomo is uh not apologizing
he is not backing down an inch
people are it seems that you know there
are plenty of conservatives
of social media that we're kind of
celebrating and saying he's going down
he's going down for this
he might i'm not ready to say that he
won't
but i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't put
all my money on it okay
i wouldn't i wouldn't bet my life
savings on this actually bringing andrew
cuomo down
because at the end of the day even if
even if everyone seems to be turning on
him right now the media is turning on
him
his fellow democrats in new york are
he is still at the end of the day a
democrat
and even for andrew cuomo that uh
provide that is a force field that can
protect you from almost anything
and that's why he's taking this approach
rather than apologizing
he uh held up you know he he spoke to
the media afterwards
had a televised address did not
apologize
basically accused all these women of
lying
and then he also explained uh he
explained much of this away
by claiming that well he gropes and
manhandles
everyone not just attractive women and
that's supposed to make it all better
let's listen to some of
andrew cuomo here i do it with everyone
black and white young
and old straight
to an lgbtq powerful people
friends strangers
people who i meet on the street
after the event the woman told the press
that she took offense
at the gesture and for that
i apologize another woman stated
that i kissed her on the forehead at our
christmas party
and that i said ciao bella
now i don't remember doing it but i'm
sure that i did
i do kiss people on the forehead
i do kiss people on the cheek i
do kiss people on the hand i do embrace
people i do hug people
men and women i do on occasion say
ciao bella on occasion
i do slip and say sweetheart
or darling or honey i do banter with
people
i do tell jokes some better than others
i am the same person in public
as i am in private yeah well that's part
that's part of the problem there uh
cuomo because you're a horrible person
in public
so hey guys i'm horrible in public
what'd you expect
i mean that is in some ways a kind of
oddly powerful argument i suppose
but this this is this is his response
and if you're just listening to the
audio podcast
you might have missed the slideshow that
he assembled and put together
where he was talking about all the
people that he gropes and then there was
a slideshow of him groping
people of all different races
ethnicities creeds
and so on look i grope everyone okay
that no one is safe from me i'll i'll i
will i will grope and touch anyone black
white young old
the postman the cashier at home depot
the disabled humans animals
if space aliens landed here i would
grope them too in a heartbeat
it's what i do that's his defense
uh and it was surprisingly not very
convincing or compelling
to a lot of people though again it
doesn't mean that he's actually going to
suffer any real consequence for this
whatsoever
and he's obviously not gonna step down
himself his his uh he's he's wagering on
the fact that he's a democrat and he can
ride this one out
and he's probably right about that now
as far as the accusations themselves i
did read a little bit of the report
and uh at least some of the sort of
summary summaries of the findings
and some of what he's accused of doing
is
clearly clearly goes beyond being
merely inappropriate uh he's accused in
some cases of
grabbing women under underneath their
shirts and so on there's like sex
that is sexual assault um that goes
beyond
sexual harassment that's that's the
accusation anyway
but it is also odd when when you have
claims like that okay that's sexual
harassment or rather that's sexual
assault
but then in the report they also include
things like
uh he he has he referred to some women
as single mamas
and at another point called them mingle
mamas whatever whatever that means
uh he said at one point he was talking
to some female assistant or something
and he said that uh
he really wants to take a woman on a
motorcycle ride
into the mountains i don't know if
that's some kind of euphemism or if he
actually just
literally just wants to go to the
mountains on a motorcycle whatever it is
but those kinds of calling someone a
single mama
that's kind of weird i mean arguably
inappropriate
if they're your employee but it's not
illegal i
wouldn't even call that sexual
harassment in fact i would i would not
call that sexual harassment
so you're kind of lumping that stuff in
with
what would be if it actually happened
straight up
straightforward sexual assault
um and so that raises some questions
though i don't doubt that the guy's a
creep and yet
i put all this to the side because
all of this pales in comparison
to the fact that andrew cuomo killed
thousands of elderly people
and he did kill them he consigned them
to their death
he signed their death warrants okay he
locked them
in nursing homes with people that he
knew to be infected by this virus
that primarily kills the elderly in
nursing homes
okay he he locked them in a room with a
with a with a
with a bomb and lit the fuse
so it's it's hard for me to care about
sexual harassment
complaints it's hard for me to muster
any real
outrage about this given that he
again killed thousands of elderly people
when i think of of andrew cuomo and the
terrible things that he's done
that will to me always be the first
thing that comes to mind and i don't
really need to think about anything else
so if he does go down for for this the
sexual harassment
[Music]
what what will it say about our culture
that this is what brings him down
that he could murder thousands of
elderly people and suffer
no consequence for remember this was
known the nursing home scandal was
known when he was still
um being
hailed as a hero across the country
especially by the media
and he got the big book deal and he went
on a book tour
and you had people in the media even men
like trevor noah
describing themselves as homosexuals
that happened
after we knew about him condemning
thousands of elderly people to
a horrible death so he suffered no
consequence for that at all and that
might be understating in fact he was
celebrated for that
um and then it comes out that he made
inappropriate comments to women in the
workplace
and made an uncomfortable workplace
environment for women
as the attorney general says and that's
the thing
that makes people go whoa whoa whoa
hang on a second this crosses a line
here hold on wait a second
okay you kill you kill uh thousands of
elderly people
that's one thing we can overlook that
but you called a woman a single mama
no sir we can't accept that
is totally demented and deranged
that this is the thing now i know you
could say
well they're both bad and we could be
upset about both
yes they're both bad but one
is on a totally different plane when
you're talking about
mass murder as opposed to what is
mostly inappropriate comments
now there were again a few accusations
of actual physical contact being made
but most of the accusations are about
inappropriate comments
and this is being called a sexual
harassment scandal after all
even by the media so you've got
inappropriate comments down here and
then up here you've got mass murder
yeah they're both bad but but i can't
make equal space
in my heart to be equally outraged by
both
i'm so outraged by the mass murder that
it doesn't
the sexual harassment claim it's it's
there's there's no room for that
in terms of of of my outrage
you know uh john wayne gacy murdered
dozens of young men and when i think
about john wayne gacy
that's what comes to mind that's like
all i need to know about him
it may be true in fact i wouldn't be
surprised if you told me that he was
also rude
to his next door neighbor and made
inappropriate comments but
it would just seem weird if you said hey
john wayne gacy yeah he he
he murdered you know 30 young men
he also made inappropriate comments to
his next door neighbor and we could be
upset about both you know
we can but
how can you even put those two things in
the same sentence is my question
all right let's move on here's something
good something that will cheer you up
really cheer you up okay this is
actually good this is uh tamyra mensah
stock who's our olympic gold medal
winning women's
and wrestler after her big win she was
talking to the media and we know what
what we very often get from these
olympic athletes
when they win they use it as an
opportunity to complain about america to
complain about everything they're
you know they're they've won a medal but
they're so upset um
but this woman tamyra has taken a very
different approach and just listen to
this
of course i surprise myself it's by the
grace of god i'm able to even move my
feet
like i just leave it in his hands and i
pray that all the practice that
the hell that my freaking coaches put me
through pays off and
every single time it does and i get
better and better and it's so weird that
there is no cap to the limit that i can
do
and i'm i'm excited to see what what i
have next
last question for you that american flag
around your shoulders looks pretty good
how does that feel to represent your
country like this it feels
amazing i love representing the us i
freaking love
living there i love it and i'm so happy
i get to represent
u-s-a
okay there's an olympic athlete we can
actually root for we found
one at least there might be a few others
and that's wonderful
you know that is it just gratitude is
such an appealing characteristic
um and humility is such an appealing
characteristic
and you think about the women's usa
soccer team megan rappino
compare the two megan rapido is such an
unappealing
sort of viscerally disgusting person
because she's had all the success in the
world and she's
no gratitude no humility all she does is
complain
all the money she makes is not enough i
don't make as much as the men
yeah well well people watch men's soccer
they don't care about women's soccer
nobody cares about this they don't watch
it
yeah i still want the same amount of
money so all she can do is complain it's
just so disgusting and unappealing and
no one wants
and you compare that to um to this woman
again tamyra mensa stock
and there's a woman you just you want to
root for her you want her to succeed
i i don't i don't care at all about
women's wrestling i have to admit
but i want her to succeed this is the
one and only women's wrestler that uh
that i actually care about and i'm happy
for her success
because of that humility and that
gratitude and um
and but it's also sad in another way
that
that um this is is now rare
not to take anything away from her at
all
but you know 10 years ago or 20 years
ago
to have an athlete saying everything she
said there we we we would all be happy
about it and we would say well that's
that's great we're very happy for them
but it wouldn't get the kind of
attention at least you know this is
getting a lot of attention from at least
conservatives and
just normal people the media is is not
paying a lot of attention they're not
going to extol her
and praise her the way that they do
losers like megan rapino
or you know or someone like
simone biles but in the public anyway
she's getting a lot of attention a lot
of praise
you go back 20 years or something or
even more recently than that and uh yeah
people would be very happy but it's but
like
most athletes would have responded that
way especially in the olympic stage
you go back not that long ago and this
is like what every
american olympic athlete was saying
and now it is so rare and so refreshing
that it's
you know it's like you watch that kind
of gratitude it's it's a it's a it's a
drink of of cold water in a desert
and it feels very refreshing so that's
the sad part of it but even so
um great to see that from
tamyra mensah stock okay a couple other
things we have to mention
uh what do we got so the director of the
nih francis collins
claimed yesterday that vaccinated
parents
must wear masks at home with their kids
that's what he said now i'll play this
for you and later on he would backtrack
and kind of imply that he didn't really
say that but
you listen to this and you tell me if if
that's what you're picking up from this
let's
listen uh you have heard those stories
coming out of louisiana pediatric
icus where there are kids as young as a
few months old who are sick from this
that is rare certainly younger people
are less likely to fall
ill but anybody who tries to tell you ah
you don't have to worry about it if
you're a young healthy person
there's many counter examples all around
us now well so yeah
you do need to think about it and that's
the reason why the recommendations
are for kids under 12 that they avoid
being in places where they might get
infected which means recommendations
of mask wearing in schools and that at
home
parents of unvaccinated kids should be
thoughtful about this and the
recommendation is to wear masks there as
well let me just follow up i know that's
uncomfortable i know it seems
weird but it is the best way to protect
your kids
okay he said at home the recommendation
is to wear masks
there as well i know that's weird it's
uncomfortable
no no uh francis it's not weird or
uncomfortable well it is
but i would prefer to use a word like
psychotic
it is psychotic
uh to to suggest that or to do it
because what you're saying is if you
wear the mask in public wear it at home
so wear the mask
all the time every waking moment and
maybe even
even when you're sleeping wear the mask
all the time
that's what he suggested now he went
after the backlash to this
people reacting the way any rational
person should to
that kind of suggestion you should be
wearing medical masks all the time
including in your own home
uh he came back around and said well i i
bungled the messaging a little bit i
didn't really mean that
what do you mean you didn't mean that
that's exactly what you said
it was not a slip of the tongue it was a
very deliberate statement
and he even acknowledges that it's weird
but yet he said it
so this wasn't this was an intentional
thing
and because the public reacted to it the
way they did um
that's why the nih backed off of it
if there had not been that reaction then
they would have just stuck with that
yeah wear the mask at home
which only goes to show you know we talk
about living in a lawless country and
and we are but so much
of the lawlessness from the government
requires the willing participation and
cooperation and
acquiescence of the public
if the public says absolutely not i am
just
not going to do this if if everyone
together gets together and says that
what are you going to do arrest all of
us you start passing the mask passing
the mask mandates i'm we're not doing it
it's not gonna do it put us all in jail
go ahead
if we all were to say that or even most
of us
then a lot of this stuff goes away
because it has to
it requires us to participate and
cooperate
all right um i also want this more
covent news while we're on the subject
this is here's
this from the hill it says new york city
will require proof of vaccination for
workers and customers who want to
participate
in indoor activities including dining in
restaurants working out in gyms
and attending theater performance
performances according to mayor bill de
blasio
bill de blasio gave a press conference
talking about this new measure and let's
listen to that so today i announce a new
approach
which we're calling the key to nyc pass
the key to new york city when you hear
those words
i want you to imagine the notion that
because
someone's vaccinated they can do all the
amazing things
that are available in this city this is
a miraculous place
literally full of wonders and if you're
vaccinated
all that's going to open up to you
you'll have the key you can open the
door but if you're unvaccinated
unfortunately
you will not be able to participate many
things that's the point we're trying to
get across
it's time for people to see vaccination
as literally necessary
to living a good and full and healthy
life the key to nyc pass will be a first
in the nation approach it will require
vaccination for workers and customers
in indoor dining in indoor fitness
facilities
indoor entertainment facilities this is
going to be a requirement
the only way to patronize these
establishments
indoors will be if you're vaccinated at
least one dose
the same for folks in terms of work
they'll need at least
one dose this is crucial
because we know that this will encourage
a lot more vaccination we've seen it
already he really does look like
gumby and rex ryan had a baby doesn't he
and this the way that they want to talk
about lawless tyranny
and it just makes it all the worse in a
lot of ways that it's approach
he's talking to us like he's a preschool
teacher
and we're his we're his students
and he's saying now you got to follow
the rules or you won't be able to go to
recess you want to go to recess
you got to follow the rules
taking away our privileges
only the privileges here are just
participating in society
going out in public and participating in
society that is a that is a privilege
that the mayor can just take away from
you can't do that anymore
and the wording is very revealing
because he says that you we want you to
see it
as if getting a vaccine is a key to
living a health a good and healthy life
which isn't the same thing as saying
that getting the vaccine actually is the
key to
a good and healthy life that's not the
claim he's making
he's saying that we're going to
artificially set it up
so that you can't live a good and
enjoyable life
without the vaccine
which is which is an interesting way of
putting it
and none of this stuff isn't if mayor
bill de blasio
actually believes himself that the
vaccines work then none of this would be
necessary putting aside whether he has
the authority to do this which he
doesn't
because he's not actually a dictator
he's a he's a mayor he's not an emperor
okay
he's not an egyptian pharaoh he's he's
the mayor of a city
in in what's supposed to be a free
country but if he really believed
that the vaccine worked then what what's
what is the point of any of this
then you get the vaccine you you're you
know you'll you'll be healthy and you'll
be relatively safe at least as far as
the covey goes
no matter what anybody else does
but instead he says the only way to keep
everyone safe is if the
unvaccinated people are forced to stay
in their homes locked in there
are cast off into leper colonies
that is an odd approach if you actually
believe in the efficacy of the vaccines
all right moving now to reading youtube
comments this is from john he says hey
matt just the other day in savannah i
witnessed a similar panhandle stunt in a
parking garage on the back of their car
they had written about to pop the
question will you buy me a drink
disgusting that kind of gives away that
you're going to pop the question doesn't
it
you've written it on the windshield of
your car
um all right gothic serpent says
matt dude you really need to start being
a little more diversified man i really
like you but you spend way too much time
talking about transsexuals and way too
much time on individual freaks that at
the end of the day really don't warrant
you spending so much over time over
analyzing
there's so much important things going
on and you literally never address other
matters
i'm not saying the stuff that you've
been talking about isn't warranted
i really feel like you're selling
yourself and your fans a little bit
short
and as you are truly incredibly
intelligent and well that out guy i
think we all will be better off
if you may be opined about other matters
as well
literally never address other matters i
never do
i'll be just off the top of my head this
week we're three days into the week
i've talked about what the eviction
moratorium masks vaccines people who
panhandle on their cash app accounts
costco
dogs coveted in florida andrew cuomo the
babylon bee cyberbullying me
uh poo scheiste the olympics childhood
indoctrination critical race there
euthanasia
laws governing governing hiv exposure in
illinois
that's a partial list of all the things
i've talked about in three days i talk
about like eight or nine different
topics a day
okay but yeah i mean other than that
other than all of that i
literally have only talked about
transsexuals it's the only thing i've
talked about
um now is it true that i talk about the
war on gender a lot
yeah i mean every show you listen to has
certain topics that they go back to and
return to frequently
for a lot of conservative shows you're
going to hear them talk about joe biden
every day
for four years among conservatives and
liberals um if
you if you listen to a talk show or
watch something on cable news like the
only thing they talked about i mean
literally almost the only thing was
donald trump for four years
so um and some shows uh these days are
going to talk a lot about
crt or or socialism and that's going to
be a theme they return to
i talk i talk about all those things
because they're important
but the gender stuff is a persistent
theme because i think it's quite
possibly the most important and
consequential thing happening in our
culture today
and most people won't talk about it or
at least won't talk about it
as directly as i will
and so that's why i do and that's not
going to change ever
so you could decide if you want to keep
listening or not that's up to you
frankly i don't care that much maybe i
should but i don't
um maximilian says matt balances pride
and humility just perfectly
well you're right that is just one of my
many talents
um and uh
red copperfield says homeowners make
money by sitting on their
rent is a money that goes nowhere
uh it's not an investment
well right that's i don't know if this
is supposed to be you know if you're
trying to make a point about landlords
and if this is supposed to be supportive
of landlords or not but
you are correct though that if you're a
homeowner you
you accrue equity just by owning a home
it's an investment
which is why in most the vast majority
of people renting right now
probably should not be renting if you
know that you're going to be in a place
very temporarily
then yeah renting makes sense but if
you're in a place and you and you are
planning to be there for a while
it just doesn't make any sense you're
gonna have to well
right now i guess you could live there
you could you know if you're a moocher
and a thief and you don't mind
being that then you could rent somewhere
and not even pay but under normal
circumstances
you got to pay either way the question
is
do you want to pay someone else's
mortgage
or pay off your own and then you get to
have the equity
and you get to own the thing when it
comes down to it that's really the
question i think obviously
the latter is the better option you know
for some reason people
seem to love watching a group of guys
get together
backstage smoke cigars drink whiskey
talk about
the state of the world because people
seem to love it we thought it'd be extra
cool
if you would join us well they thought
it'd be cool if you joined us
they didn't ask my opinion that's why
we're giving away a trip for two to come
hang with the daily wire host backstage
here at our nashville studio where you
can meet us
tour the studios and offices get a great
swag bag of merch and watch us debate on
the show live
but you're gonna wanna hurry because
this is your last chance so
if you're not a member yet head to
dailywire.com backstage and enter code
backstage in
uh at checkout for 25 off your
membership and you get automatically
entered to win
one of the coolest trips you'll ever
take and remember if you do come
don't look me in the eye and don't speak
to me also our newest podcast morning
wire has been
hovering at the top of the charts on
apple and spotify since its release and
it's pretty clear why because it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so
subscribe now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts
and leave a five star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so the rapper de baby has uh
i can't even say his name without
laughing uh the rapper the baby
dub i don't know how to emphasize duh
baby
the baby the rapper de babies found
himself in the middle of a full-blown pr
pr crisis stemming from comments he made
at a concert recently
and by the way please don't confuse the
baby with little baby or
sata baby or bad baby these are all
different people different babies i
think
uh the baby is is is the one who's in
trouble now because he used anti-gay
slurs during a concert
in miami recently at one point during
the show
he called for people who don't have hiv
to put their cell phone lights up
uh now if you haven't been to a concert
since 2005 just you know the cell phone
light has replaced the lighter
so you know you put that up like like
people used to put lighters up at
concerts he also called for men who
haven't performed certain sexual acts on
other men in the parking lot
to put their cell phone lights up it
isn't clear why he said this or
why he brought it up but it would appear
to be some kind of joke that he made
and the joke did not land quickly other
artists came out and condemned the baby
young artists like dua lipa whoever that
is
i don't know i can't even say these
people's names
um and old artists like elton john and
madonna also came out many others spoke
out to chastise the baby and
put him in time out like so many babies
before him
and then the financial penalties really
kicked in lollapalooza dropped him from
their lineup
i heart radio festival dropped him he
was dumped by austin city limits and the
governor's ball
he was banned from performing at his
cousin's birthday party
uh the point is he he quickly became
persona non grata
across the music industry now the baby
tried to satiate the mob
by addressing the situation on instagram
in the immediate aftermath
his remarks were and we'll play them for
you i think you'll agree they're quite
eloquent
and uh and worth listening to let's
listen
one time i'm gonna get back to giving my
love to my fans
that's what i'm saying because what me
and my fans do at the live show
it don't concern you on the internet or
you better
on the internet it's not your business
you know what i'm saying like what i do
at a live show
is for the audience at the live show
it'll never
translate correctly to somebody looking
at
a little five six second clip from
korea on a phone
it just don't work like that like you
know because regardless of what you
talking about how the internet and
twisted up my [ __ ]
me and all my fans at the show the gay
ones and the straight ones we turned
up i'm telling my boy that was at the
front of stage left over there by where
i jumped at
ask him he got clips all on his the
whole night was recording we were
turning the whole night
my boy had the crop top on front row
yeah out there in that jungle in that
water
yeah he out there he's standing on the
rail got them cutting up he
words i saw him i'm wrapping him
indeed it is not your business
and and he raises a good point i mean
there was a guy with a crop top in the
front row
and he was turned what else do you want
the guy with the crop top was turned so
it's not your business
end of discussion except it was not the
end of discussion shockingly the
statement that
he released there didn't do anything to
quell the outrage
so he tried again with a written
statement and full apology
i'll read this statement to you and i
don't know it just sounds a little bit
different
from what we just heard there in
instagram but
i don't know you tell me he said this is
what was the statement that was
published from
the baby social media moves so fast that
people want to demolish you before you
even have the opportunity to grow
educate and learn from your mistakes
as a man who has made his own way from
very difficult circumstances having
people i know publicly working against
me
knowing that what i needed was that
education on these topics and guidance
has been challenging i appreciate the
many people who came to me with kindness
who reached out to me privately to offer
wisdom
education and resources that's what i
needed
and it was received i want to apologize
to the lgbtq plus community
for the hurtful and triggering comments
i made again i apologize for my
misinformed comments about hiv
aids and i know education on this is
important
love to all god bless now
now if i know the baby and i don't know
him but still
you know i don't think he wrote that i'm
guessing he is not the one who wrote the
phrase
i apologize to the lgbtq plus community
for the
hurtful and triggering comments but
whoever wrote it
it was not enough the baby has crossed a
line
that you can't cross these days which is
interesting
because it's not as though those
comments about gay people were the first
objectionable things he's ever said in
his life his songs
you know the songs that these music
festivals have hired him to come and
perform
are each a succession of one
objectionable statement after another
in fact those songs the songs that again
the music festivals
hired him to perform perform and then
banned him from performing
contains statements and ideas that are
far more outrageous and offensive than
anything he said about hiv or gay people
he actively promotes murder drug dealing
violent crime of all sorts the
objectification and murder of women
among other things just one verse on one
song will likely
likely contain all of these things for
example one of his biggest
singles is a song called shug which is
an homage to uh
suge knight who's the murderous former
ceo of death row records
who's now serving time in a maximum
security uh prison
for running a guy down in his car and
killing him
and the song lives up to its namesake
i'll play a quick clip just to give you
an
idea of uh of what this guy is all about
let's
let's play this pack in the middle it's
gone
she like i smell cologne yeah i just
found a deal i'm on
[Music]
[Music]
truly a masterpiece and you know the
editors love me when i send them stuff
like that
here you go guys spend the next 15 hours
editing this
to get all the customers up um if you
weren't able to understand anything
there
let me run through some of the
highlights here's what he says
the first n word play i'm a body in
n-word i just check my balance i'll
probably pull up to your hood
get caught with your then i'm popping
them both you disrespect me and i'll
beat you
up in front of your partners and
children take 20k and put that on your
head and make one of your partners come
kill you
uh etc and so forth now to review
in just the first verse of one song he's
killing someone
then killing someone else along with
that guy's girlfriend then he's
assaulting someone in front of their
children and then he's putting a hit out
on someone else
and later in that song he blows
someone's head off uh shoots somebody in
front of their
grandmother and has sex with various
in his words not mine he also said that
he also seems to brag about having sex
with a girl in grade school
saying that he pulls up after school to
teach her some
now i hope i'm not misinterpreting but i
can only assume he's not bragging about
giving actual math lessons
now um the baby is is not any different
from the average rapper but
does that make it okay to openly
romanticize death and slaughter and
sexual violence
and if you're upset about derogatory
comments about lgbt people
which means you're taking what this guy
says seriously you're holding him to a
certain standard in his speech
then why wouldn't you be upset about
literally everything else he's ever said
in any of his songs just consider the
absolute absurdity of a de baby fan
singing along as he talks about shooting
hoes in the face and then going whoa
whoa whoa
hey don't be insensitive to lgbt people
the baby come on have some class young
man
please understand something i am not
equating his song lyrics with what he
said about gay people and aids
i would never do that they're not the
same because the song lyrics are a
thousand times worse
they are worse not only in their content
but in their effect
you know the violent crime problem in
our cities is largely driven by young
men
who grew up without fathers in the home
those young men look to guys like the
baby as
role models these rappers are are
are the only male role models that many
of these kids have
so when these role models are standing
in front of them and explicitly saying
hey it's cool to shoot and kill people
if you have a beef with them or even if
you don't
that has an impact that resonates it's
not a coincidence that probably close to
100
of the murderers arrested in the city in
in you know in any given city listen to
rap music
i bet we could comb through every
penitentiary in the country
in the country and find like two
classical music fans if that many
it's not a matter of rap music directly
causing violent crime
we're talking about influence the
messages that you pump into your
eardrums every day
will influence you of course they will
and the messages from guys like the baby
are not just negative not just bad
but they're almost absurdly evil
cartoonishly cruel
only the people influenced by them don't
see them as cartoonish
and the rappers themselves don't see it
as cartoonish
only well-adjusted adults can hear these
kinds of songs and find them laughably
ridiculous
the rap fans who were upset about the
baby's comments about gay people
will probably hear what i'm saying right
now in scoff insisting that lyrics are
just words and
they don't mean anything they don't have
any real impact
and yet when it comes to the comments
about gay people they certainly do think
it matters
and it does mean something and it does
have an impact
so for them some words are violence and
yet words that literally and directly
encourage violence
are harmless it's completely backwards
and incoherent
and lying at the heart of all this is a
demented and vacuous moral code
which excuses nearly all evil applauds
nearly all sin
except when it upsets a member of the
protected class it's a kind of elitism
except far more morally vacuous than
normal elitism
and for all of those reasons
mob which is selectively outraged at the
baby
is today canceled
and uh the baby is cancelled too
but not even because of what he said
about gay people uh i'm more concerned
again about the fact that he's going
around
encouraging people to kill each other
that to me seems like
the bigger issue uh so all those people
are canceled today and we'll leave it
there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show
morning wire on today's episode new
york's attorney general finds that
governor cuomo
sexually harassed multiple women new
york city issues a city-wide
proof-of-vaccination mandate and
whistleblowers expose more troubling
developments at the border
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire